hi welcome to part four of game theory
in breaking bad
the scene we're going to discuss is
breakage
the setup to the scene is that jesse is
short on some money because two drug
addicts have stolen from one of his
dealers
in his meeting with walt he tries to
play off the loss of money as not a big
deal
but walt explains why it's very
important they have to take this
seriously and why they have to retaliate
so here's the scene
so let's discuss the scene
the important part is that you see a
very big difference in how jesse and
walt think about the problem
jesse thinks that the loss of product is
breakage and he compares it to the loss
of merchandise and kmart
but this is another example of how jesse
is stuck in a static decision theory
framework
walt thinks about the game theory
it's not about the money in fact he
throws the money right back at jesse
he explains it's all a game of
reputation
once the word gets out that jesse is
someone that can be stolen from
everyone's going to try and do this
it'll be a complete chaos and it will
not be a sustainable model for the
future
so walt instructs jesse to take action
and in the next part we're going to see
what actually happens and how
jesse does develop a reputation
thanks for watching and you can catch me
on my new decisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker